welcome back to Las Vegas now the rise
Festival brings people together with the
purpose of healing growing and making
long-lasting memories through the
tradition of releasing lanterns into the
sky joining us to tell us more is the
founder of the rise Festival Dan Hill
Dan how are you I'm well thanks Jillian
how are you I'm great we're really
excited for this event to return in
October tell us a little bit about it
for maybe people who haven't been there
and just how it all came about
well we started rise in in 2014 I've
been producing events for about a decade
before that and most events are very
stimulating they're very external and we
wanted to create an event that was more
still more about going internal and um
so we've built this amazing venue out on
out on the Jean dry lake bed where
people can come look inside themselves
and release some lanterns I think now
more than ever we all just need a moment
to kind of step back and take some peace
and quiet in and the dry lake beds out
there are so beautiful we're looking at
some pictures now it's such a cool
experience so tell us how it works and
what else do you have going on out there
in addition to the lanterns being
released yeah well we're most the
lantern release is what we're most
famous for we were the first Lantern
event in the U.S and and I believe we're
the biggest in the world still
um but and and that area happens in an
area called the compass it's a it's a
360 stage with everyone sitting all
around it surrounded by these beautiful
tiki torches so during the day at the
compass we have live music this year we
have gone gone beyond and ryex
Performing leading into the release and
and then we have you know we have about
a dozen high quality food trucks great
food and drinks for people to enjoy
during that time and then this year
we've added a new area called space
apart which is further out on the lake
bed where we have interactive art for
people to explore during the days you
can write let you can read letters of
Love written by the community or write
letters that will mail for you to loved
ones
um and then everyone returns to to the
compass from basically sunset at seven
about an hour after Sunset they ride on
their lanterns and release them then
after fireworks we'll have have all new
art out there on the space apart that
will be lit up differently we'll have
dance out there
we also have a I forgot we have a
meditation and sound bath during the
days out in space part as well what an
incredible experience and I'm just so
happy to hear it's continuing to grow
and you're expanding on it and I know in
the past you guys have sold out before
the event even started so if people want
to get tickets how can they get involved
and it's October 7th and 8th right it's
October 7th today there are still
tickets available then go to
risefestival.com to purchase tickets
Friday night Saturday's nearly sold out
we have a few more for Friday as well
well Dan thank you so much for bringing
this experience to the United States and
especially here in Las Vegas I love
seeing the lanterns float away into the
sky so we're really excited about it
thank you for joining us and the rise
Lantern and music festival is being held
on October 7th and 8th that's at the dry
Jean lake bed Mojave Desert you can get
tickets at risefestival.com Mercedes
over to you